قد يرى الرئيس جو بايدن هذا في
طريقه لمقابلة قادة
السعودية تم محو أحياء كاملة من مدينة جدة التاريخية الثانية في المملكة من
أجل
التحديث
أو قد يرى هذه
الآلاف والآلاف من المنازل الجديدة
التي يتم بناؤها بأوامر حكومية ،
ما من غير المرجح أن يراه بايدن هم
الناس.  التقينا الذين أخبرونا أنهم
غير سعداء بهدم منازلهم
ولكنهم يخشون التحدث علانية
أن التغييرات السكنية هي جزء من
إصلاحات ضخمة أصدرها
زعيم المملكة في انتظار ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان
الذي يقول منتقدون سعوديون خارج البلاد
إنه يفشل
من الواضح جدًا أن هناك فشلًا
كبيرًا في الرؤية بشكل أساسي لأنها رؤية
من
شخص واحد ومع ذلك تتجول في شوارع جينر القديمة
كما فعلنا وستجد الكثير
من المعجبين لولي العهد عبد المجيد
كان أحدهم  هم
نبيل عبدالله آخر
حلمي
يحصل أطفالنا على فرصة جيدة
الآن نشهد هذا
في أه
النسخة الجديدة 2030
ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان '
أنا معه أنا أتفق معه في
المكان الذي عاشت فيه أجيال من عائلته
وعملت في تجديدات ولي العهد
لإعادة المنازل القديمة
إلى الحياة ،
لكن ماذا يحدث إذا لم يسلمه
لا يستطيع تقديم
سبب اعتقادك بأننا سلبي  الآن
ترى الإيجابيات من شيء ما
يحدث ،
لماذا تعتقد أن البداية إذا
رأينا الشيء السلبي
لا يمكننا أن نخطو خطوة واحدة
ولكن أحلام MBs كبيرة ويمكن أن تجعل
أو تحطم البلد
نيون مدينة مستقبلية لم يتم بناؤها بعد ،
فهي مركز الزلزال و  إذا كان لولي
العهد طريقه فهو المحرك الاقتصادي
لأجيال قادمة ، ولكن على الرغم من عدة
سنوات في صناعة مقاطع الفيديو للمطورين
، فكل ما لدينا إذن من الحكومة
للتصوير ، لم يتم حتى الآن تسهيل
رؤى الملوك العظيمة ليست شيئًا
جديدًا هنا آخر الملك عبد الله  إذا كانت نسخته قد
غطتها قبل خمسة عشر عامًا
، فستكون نصف حجم
البحرين الإجمالي وثلاثة أضعاف حجم مانهاتن ثلاثة
أضعاف حجم مانهاتن ، نعم الواقع
لا يمكن أبدا  اصطدم بالخيال
مئات الآلاف من الوظائف المقترحة التي
لم تتحقق أبدًا
، ستكون رؤية MBS بمثابة اختبار له على
كل المستويات إذا كانت هناك وظائف
ومستقبل أكثر إشراقًا لمعظم الناس ، ثم
أيام سعيدة ، ولكن إذا
فشلت إصلاحاته حتى ،
فكيف سيستجيب إذا  من خلال
القمع
،
يمكن أن
تنهار علاقته مع الرئيس بايدن
والقادة الغربيين الآخرين في الوقت الحالي.
وعود فيما يتعلق بالمملكة العربية السعودية
وشقيقة إم بي إس هاثاواي ، وهي
ناشطة في مجال حقوق المرأة ، تم إطلاق سراحها من السجن السعودي ، ولكن
ليس البلد بعد وقت قصير من مطالبة
بايدن بالإفراج عنها في أوائل العام الماضي ،
فهي تخشى أن تقرأ MBS زيارة بايدن لأن
الموافقة على المزيد من الاعتقالات
الجديدة لن تتوقف أبدًا حيث أن mbs  في السلطة
إنه يتعلق بالشخص الذي هو عليه والشيء الوحيد
الذي يمكن أن يغير الأشياء هو
المساءلة من العالم أ
سيكون وقت بايدن في جدة تذكيرًا قاسيًا بالسياسة
الحقيقية في أصعب
أوقاتها نيك روبرتسون CNN جدة المملكة العربية السعودية